je t'aime à l'italienne
ouah je t'aime à l'italienne
j'ai au fond du coeur une drôle de
chanson sicilienne
que tu sais par coeur carmat vireuse
tu es
je l'aimais
et fort qu'il est
quand
caen reste
hu
j'étais mal
[Musique]
je sois là
si sûr
un jour
je chante
ô toi
je ne sais pas
gfr
notre histoire
ressembler la dolce vita
j'ai joué plus
tous les violons
la scala
il
iny roma
un émoi
dans mes rêves j'ai jeté
en état
derrière
[Musique]
la mairie
un monde
[Musique]
je ne sais
je tienne
des lieux
hu
je t'aime
d'ailleurs
je sais
je n'ai pas
et je
voiture vous
situe pas là
plus
[Musique]
oh
je ne sais pas
gfr
g
et je ne vous
si tu pars là
quand
déçu mais joule
musica
je chante avec lui
[Musique]